i'm so curious um had you talked to
marvel about other things prior than
moon night like how did you guys
actually hook up i made
small egyptian films one egyptian one
plus thing two egyptians and then i my
films went to big festival scan and uh
berlin and i mean canon venice and um
you have your agents looking for
projects for you i've been known to be
mr no or mostly say no to most of the
projects but uh
once they sent me this project i was
hooked this is what i'm looking for
okay it's a big budget thing
but in the same time it's what i care
about is the intimate story the story of
mark and steven is something fascinating
i would i would have done it without
action in it i don't care i love that
and i felt this is an extension of my
movies
and
if i put my formula if i put
something that is grounded
the way i'm imagining i want to act do
the action the darkness that i can bring
i can i can add something to the table
and um me and my wife put a pitch 200
page pitch my wife sara gohar is my
partner my co-writer my she's a producer
now on the show
the moment we were done with the pitch
we looked at each other and i told her
sarah we're gonna get that job or
something is wrong in the with the world
because it's not just we covered
everything because we covered the
locations the tone
the music the score the action um uh
what's how we how we see egypt how we
see every location and um even how to
develop the characters but um
it's like we clicked with the project
it's not just covering stuff it's just
that we knew that we are the best people
to tell that story and in a lot of other
cases and that's why maybe i didn't
apply to other jobs
i didn't feel the same thing i in this
one i felt that and um
ironically enough that pitch became the
bible for the show and it is the show
today
so one day i'm gonna share that pitch
and you would be amazed two years later
it's uh before it and it's
it's exactly the show some even imagery
didn't wasn't in the show and i we've
put it in the
uh uh credit scenes i know exactly what
you're saying listen i was gonna save
this to the end but since you were so
passionate about bringing this to life i
just have to ask you um have you talked
to marvel about doing a second season is
doing more something you're interested
in i want to
let you in a secret
marvel is so secretive
that what's your experience is what am i
what
my experience
uh ironically i know nothing
and sometimes you ask yourself why did i
do a bad job but i think this is the way
they do it thank god they love the show
they keep expressing every day how much
they love the show but it's not like any
other show meaning on the other show
outside the marvel universe meaning
any tv series if it's good you know that
you're gonna get a second season but one
division was great
and you didn't get a second second
season you went to something else so
what i'm absolutely sure of
that moonlight is staying staying for a
long time in my opinion that's that's
just a prediction he's so interesting
that i think he's gonna stay but what's
gonna happen next is he gonna be a tv
another season is it going to be a film
is he going to join someone else
my guess is yours
i i've heard this from every director um
what coming in from the outside someone
who has not worked with marvel before i
am curious what surprised you about
working with them on this series that
perhaps you weren't expecting well a
couple of things first of all i never
expected
that someone like kevin is going to be
that hands-on
he is un like what he's doing is
almost genius like i keep i i can't wrap
my hand head around it someone who's
overseeing 20 projects in the same time
and if you ask them if about a word in
the drafts that we keep changing almost
every week he knows what changed this is
how he is so hand being hands-on which
is very helpful
because if you're working with them you
have to know that those guys have the
most successful run in the history of
this
industry ever so they have secret a
secret sauce and you have to be to have
to know that you are here for a reason
you have secret sauce too so the two of
you together can bring something but
being hands on was surprising giving me
a chance to play with something like
this ip because i push the envelope i
i want it to be to push it
i wanted something that usually wouldn't
think that they want which is i wanted
to look and feel different than every
other
mcu
project which eventually is the case and
today
you might say some people keep telling
me if there's no marvel
logo at the beginning of episode one you
wouldn't think
you wouldn't necessarily know that this
is a marvel show which is something i'm
proud of and i'm i'm proud of that we
cut everything that were we deleted the
idea of any crossovers and we didn't
have need crutches we stood on on our
own and the project maybe that's the
surprise
uh rather than a crossover that we can
stand on on our own
that's probably my favorite thing about
the mcu is that they keep on reinventing
what's possible
in this universe and it's one of the
reasons i think people love it
by the way just like someone who who
who's watching from afar every two three
years if there's something that is
slightly i'm doubtful of what the
project is gonna be ah this is the this
is the superhero fatigue i'm waiting for
the fall and all of a sudden those guys
know how to turn it around and reinvent
themselves and i think hiring someone
like me is part of that hiring someone
like oscar hiring someone like ethan
names that you wouldn't associate with a
project like this but uh i want to tell
you that
if you felt that this is a different
project it's it's because of all those
people because of may because of ethan
because of oscar because of every
collaborator that felt to me that is the
right because of my egyptian composer
you know what i mean like
every one of them brought something
because of the
egyptian songs that my wife picked one
by one and i think it's a great intro to
egyptian culture did you end up with uh
the episodes are longer than some of the
other mcu shows did you end up with a
lot of deleted scenes or no it depends
on the episode but definitely there are
deleted scenes but not as much as you
think because we were we hold the record
of being one of the not one the
um uh
the least amount of additional
photography in the history of mars
so
yeah so usually there's additional
photography we have the least amount of
additional photography four days
so there isn't
it's nothing absolutely uh i and i think
part of it was that marvel allowed us to
do this thing when we meet every week
and sometimes before even shooting we
did it table reads
it was us and the writers and all the
talent sarah grant the great our great
executive uh
producer and all of us
read the script and everyone chips in
and everyone
turn every stone so in a way we we did
the job that usually is done at the at
the end which is marvel never leaves the
uh film bad
even if it's the word they're gonna
reshoot the whole thing they don't care
so we tried our best to help
from the beginning and i think that
helped a lot can you talk a little bit
about designing the costume moon knights
costume there's two versions obviously
but can can you sort of talk about how
you wanted it to look and feel and
like that
ironically we started with
steven having mr knight
having a moon night and mark having mr
knight ironically
but that's that's one of the best thing
about taking your time and developing
things you start realizing no no this
costume is for this guy this is what
works for them and we like we realize
what's the logic
the logic should be that each one of
them inspires his suit
so the suit is inspired by who you are
or what you love or what's your
imagination of a
of a suit and that's why steven who's
uh completely away from the superhero
worlds his cool thing is when they tell
him some in the suit it's a suit it's a
it's it's an almost armani suit
so
it made sense but um
i love that he had two suits and um the
one that we worked even more on was uh
the moonlight suit and i love how
different it is from everything that we
saw before in any uh superhero but i
think it tells a lot of a lot about the
story you can look at the suit and
dissect you can see that that crescent
in his that that he pulls and it's uh
it's it's a weapon you see how he's
mummified and the cape and um the
weaponry the weaponry and you see the na
the heteroglyphs on him it's just like a
such an interesting thing and on the
other hand as a director i was scared a
lot more from mr knight's suits because
a white suit like that could look so bad
on camera
yes
and it could be silly and it could be
weird but ironically the moment oscar
stepped in we felt
he it's it's no it's it's very cool and
we actually try to think of moments that
we can expand it even more on that note
i got to stop i'm just going to say
congrats and i hope it's a huge hit for
you guys
i want to thank you and i want to tell
you that even the next two episodes i'm
sure they're not going to disappoint you
they're even crazier i want to watch
watch it one day maybe with you i know
you're crazy enough to do that one day
we can watch it on a big screen together
six hours listen to me i would do that
in a heartbeat i wish they were more of
this i wish more of the marvel series
were shown on the big screen one day i'm
sure yeah the movie quality you know
what i mean
it's it's made like a movie just so you
know we there there isn't a day that we
call it a tv show we call it a movie
anyway we could keep talking i can't
wait to see the last two episodes thank
you thank you so much brother thank you